ん
me
入道いいいい
みなさんこんにちは
私はですねあのーアイディアスプレー bing
ということで
科学的ものの考え方を見つけようということを話します
より良い社会と科学ダンスの縁えにしの tammy
そして英語では3ティックウェーブ千金
in her スイング bd 出品ファンセンサー5 eea 入ってます理由
でしょうか
ではなぜ科学的ものの考え方を身につけないといけないでしょうか
1996年
21世紀の始まる前
21政権の低減という記事を原稿書いてほしい
依頼されました
20世紀に何が重要なのだろうか
3カ月長いました
そして到達したのがこの科学ゲスト
社会の橋渡し役が必要なんだということであります
これがその記事ですが
英語にも訳されてアサヒ av ニュースにもなっています
ここで
私が
考えたこと
このように我々はカーキ this の八田氏の福利を大きく受けているが同時に発達
した普遍の深刻な問題も
提起されてきた
あるいは人間の活動そのものが地球環境に負荷を与えだしているので
それから来世紀にますます深刻にタブー地球環境資源人口エネルギー問題についても
一人一人に自分の問題としての施策と決断がまとめられているだろう
そういう時代が来るだろう
そして
科学者に塗るゲームを活動ということではなくて
最先端の科学の研究成果を
そそ社会的意味を科学に慣れ親しんでいない人に
そして社会的意味については釜ピザにも改めて説明してくれる人材
つまりパークのいたぶりたーーーーが必要にな
いいかプリンターは専門用語だ単なる直役者ではなく問題を指摘し進むべき方向示唆
する
パークと実生活の橋渡しをする解説や評論社でん
そのためには
9的思考ができる人が必要であるこんなことを書きました
この新聞記事を読んで当時の中は寒明けじっ長官が科学技術社会に関する懇談会って
いう発足させました
それがこの記事のてたってことずっと後に人に教えて頂いたんですがこれから
理解増進とか service チャンネルが始まったので大変うれしく思っています
それから朝日新聞の記事を読んでですねー
本6詩を書いてほしいって言われてさらに思いを書きました
科学期日は社会の中に一層身としてくるところ96年のことです
社会と科学という対峙した関係ではなくて社会の中の科学になるだろ
でこの思いを本のタイトルにもしました
さて
これ19年前のことですそれから19年が経ちました
2015年
地球は気候変動エネルギー支援水食糧問題
日本では少子高齢化産業競争力の低下が色々問題になっています
これらの解決にはハマー記述だけではできないんですがやはり母フィスによるブレイク
するも必要です
源頼日本は
把握て想像りっこあるいはイノベーションが必要だと言われています
一方
科学実は急速に進みました日
すまっ本
グーグ sns そしてビッグデーター
これは社会構造を迎えています
あーテクノロジーもそうです
大さあ子クローニングができるようになり ip 細胞による研究が数
そしてさ
あった11デー
1000ドルくらい出せば人の
ゲノムの解読ができるようなそんな時代になってきています
声明に対する私たちの考え方も大きく変わってきています
そんな時に入っ
やはり
市民が把握で制作への参画もしてほしい言われるようになってきています
19年前と同じようにですね
なく
ソーシャルリテラシーを持った優秀なカーキ10世とそしてさえ過ぎてるし
くるは基礎知識と科学的思考ということなんですか
それを持った一般市民が必要だ
ということです
19年たって社会と科学の関係は
変わったでしょうか
確かに
子どもやお粉の理科離れのためか出前授業が進んでいます
ファースカフェも厚く市で開かれている3した声を持ってきて非常に活発になってき
ました
でもその他はどうでしょうか
19号
やはりこの最後のポイントに焦点を当ててこの場で
科学的ものの考え方を身につけましょうと is プレーティングをしています
じゃあ
学的ものの考え方ってさっきから何も言ってますけどこれはなんなんでしょうか
手を出してみました
スポーツニュースです
科学的ものの考え方は浜口だけが対象ではありません
これはちょっと古い2007年の朝日新聞の記事で
池上彰さんの新聞がダメ3
松坂大輔投手なメジャーリーグ
が初勝利をしたそのことを書いた記事です
大リーグに初登板したバス坂大介投資
見事なピッチング
朝日新聞は4月6日に浮かんでこう書いています
1回ます坂が香ばしいでマウンドでまで駆け上がると約2万3千人が入った観客席の
ファンが一斉に立ち上がり拍手を送った
うん読んでて楽しいですねー
いい気持ちになったので保管戦後も呼びますよ
mc んです
マツダ彼は駆け足でマウンドに向かう敵地カーフマンスタジアムに起きたボーイングと
わずかな感性を背負っ
わずかな歓声だって随分と違うじゃないか
確かにスタジアムは裏つソックスの判決ポストんではなく
相手チームローユアーズの本家置換雑色
相手チームのファンが多いから松坂にアブー員が多かったということか
道具新聞によって両社の異なるらしい
では y
この日の間座席は気温2度て冷え込み観衆も23170人と少なかったは松坂の投球に
熱い視線を注がれた
監修の数が少なかったかッ
そんなこと前の2つの新聞には書いてなかったそう
読んでみよう
こ鯉ほどの三叉平日のデーゲームてく止まり球場のづまり具合はほぼ半分
だが初回3リガーデン力松坂投手が小橋に出てきてマウンドに向かうと三尾川3000
人とったレッツ速さんから敵地と思えない大きな歓声
ありゃ球場のズバリ具合をほぼ半分だっけ
結構少なかったのね
ではアメリカの新聞はどうだろう
ニューヨークタイムズには3人のベテラン選手が休んだ
弱い状態のチームを相手にしたものの松坂は優れた投資であることを示した
何日のことが書いてあるぞ
相手チームが普段より弱かった
新聞屋ってこんなニュアンスが違うとは
皆さんどうでしょう同じ試合なのに
何も印象が違うんです
これはスポーツニュースに限りません
た学術報道にも公の機関の発表にも
日常のメディアの報道にも
製品の広告にも当てはまります
嘘が書いてあることもあります
嘘は書いてないんだけれどもあることをあえて書かないということで誤解招く表現に
なっていたり
不適切な誇張があるのです
それを見抜くためには
基礎知識とか撒く敵ものの考え方が必要です
今のます中投資ならない登板の話で見てみましょう
基礎知識球場の収容数
23170人と大変正確な数字はれましたけれど
この球場に
そのくらいだいたいどのくらい歌詞が入るのかなっていうか分からなかった
まったく意味がない
同条件の非核化へ吉あるいは本拠地の試合かということです
盗掘な条件があるか
jellan 選手が休んじゃ
これを
科学報道についても考えてみましょう
もちろん科学技術のすべてではないんですけれども季節四季が必要です
同条件の比較かこれは対照実験ということです
対照実験点はあることを調べたいためにそれ以外はすべて同じ条件にして比較するもの
です
例えば
新しい薬が開発されたとき
その効果があるかどうかを調べるには+以後
ギャップというものを使います
プラシーボには薬の成分は何も入っていません
因子を試験に参加する人には新訳カフらしい子かどっちが与えられたか伏せられてい
ます
なんか薬を飲んだってだけでただの行う7治っちゃったりすることもあるかですね
それから特殊な条件があるか
例えばこんな話がありました
最先端の
装置診断技術あるいは治療
そういうものを兼ね備えた中核の癌病院
その元の家よりつが地方のマイナーな病院よりも悪い
これは税金の無駄遣いだとくるべきでしょうか
それとも
このような病院には他の病院でさじを投げられた重症の患者さんが9分から
そういうことになってんじゃないかな考えることはできないでしょうか
もう少し科学的ものの考え方を一緒に見てみましょう
はく率平均統計分布金大が書いてありますが例えばこんなに違う
分布であっても平均は50です
平均50だということでいろいろ議論しても意味が何か
意味することは全く違います
もう一つ
で見てみましょう定量的な把握が必要だ
あるないっていうことはあんまり役に立ちません
どのくらいあるかが重要でそれがどんなことを意味するかというのは科学技術科学的な
知識に呼ぶ判断が必要です
またないということは科学的には証明できません
では見てみましょう
料理に使う殺到か仕様かほんの少量を図ろうと思います
まあ普通は目分量で小さじ1杯って言うんですけど
例えば無視で測るときましょう
一番左は体重計です料理の測り
そして実験に使う図りこれは私がちょっと実験に使っている1マイクログラムまで
測れる
超精密全便です
この
佐藤可士用体重計の受けても針は触れませんじゃあないんでしょうか
いや目の前にあるから今はあるって言えますかもし見えなかった
あるない言えますかもっと感度杭派カレーかけたらあるかもしれないです
科学で言えることは
あるということだけでないってことは言えないからはわかっていただきたいと思います
すべてのことにリスクとベネフィットがあります
そして常にそのトレードオフを考えています
ただ実社会で問題なのは
リスクを受ける人と頭皮ととベネフィットを受ける人が同じじゃないということです
例えば外科手術をする時黒同じです
でも
発電所と電力消費種を分かりん
こういうことを常に考えてい
それから
9的にしろが風呂で付けられることほとんどありません
間にグレーゾーンがあるんですが
科学技術の進歩するとここにちょっとでだけ上げて今日時間なんで説明をしないんです
がグレーゾーンがどんどん広がっていっています
最後に
東大に10年位前に作った
参戦いた flickr 養成プログラムついて一言お話して
私の話を終えたいと思います文系理系の大学院生対象の服全校でこれが先ほど
一番最初の話をした三振たピーターをちょっと絵で書いてみた
あの記事を書いて9年経ってやっと口にもこのようなのに予算をつけてくるようになり
ました
ただ5年間の時限だったのでその後は
駒場の教養学部の中に教養教育行動各工程の奥その中に入れていただいています
多くの方々の協力を得てできたプログラムです
そしてこれはキーワードはですねどう伝えるか p スキルばかりやるんですけどここ
は何を地帯
正しく伝えるって取りことをわかりやすく伝えるってどういうことなんだろう
そんなことまでも負荷防止て考え
ということで始めました
そのロゴマークです呉ポー台のロゴマークなんですか
こんな風にロゴマーク作りましたバックあるでしょうか
ここですまたは考えですよね
可能なんですさあイスト支え t の2つの s が寄り添ってハーモニーをつくって
こういうことを願って
このロゴマークを作りましたこのようにこんな社会が出てくるといいですね
さて皆さん科学的ものの考え方を身につける必要性
分かっていただけたでしょうか
騙されて変な商品を買わないかけ雨だけではありません
科学と社会のよりよい関係を陰版するために
アクティものの考え方を身につけましょう
どうもご静聴ありがとうございました